Now, Pokémon Go debuted only
a couple of weeks ago,
but it has more users
than Tinder and Twitter.
But some-- true--
but some say Pokémon Go
is a government
surveillance tool.
(audience laughing)
So for more on this,
let's check in
with conspiracy expert,
Mike Yard,
in the latest segment
of The Y Files.
Okay, so, Mike.
Honestly, Mike,
do you think Pokémon Go
is some sinister tool
for spying on us?
-Is Pokémon Go sinister?
-Right, no.
Larry, I hope you like
your new ophthalmologist, me,
'cause I'm about
to tear the scales
from your eyes, my brother.
But, Mike,
why would our government make
a game to monitor people?
The NSA got in trouble
for collecting phone call data.
(imitates buzzer)
You lose.
Of course, Pokémon Go was
created by the government, man,
but not for your
garden-variety sheeple control.
Pokémon Go was created...
to discredit Black Lives Matter.
Read it and weep, my brother.
Read it and weep.
(audience chuckles)
-Mike, that's absurd.
-(audience applause)
-That doesn't even make sense.
-It's all here, my brother.
-No, no, no. No, no.
-It's all here.
Pokémon Go is
like a stupid time-waster.
It has absolutely nothing to do
with Black Lives Matter.
Oh, come on, Larry Shill-more.
-Oh.
-(laughter)
You play by walking around
looking down at your phone.
Okay. All right.
What? What?
So we can't record what the cops
are doing to us.
(applause)
-Wait.
-Gotta think.
Hold on a second.
So you're saying, like the game
is so powerful and engrossing,
you just ignore everything
around you?
Hell, yeah.
It's that seductive, Larry.
I mean, they got Charizard,
they got Pikachu.
They got Vulpix.
They got Eevees.
It's like crack to us, Larry.
Crack.
Hello.
♪ Gotta catch 'em all. ♪
-I mean...
-It's not like crack, Mike.
It's like crack, bro.
But we have...
But, Mike, it's that way
for everybody that plays it,
-not just black people.
-(scoffs)
You know what, your ancestors
must have been Nubian,
'cause you love denial.
(laughter, applause)
Let me ask you...
-Let me ask you something,
Larry. -Mike...
-What? -What's your favorite
character, huh? Chumpasaur?
Mike, that doesn't even
make sense.
All right, look...
Okay, look, prove it.
How is Pokémon GO a trap
specifically rigged
to catch black people?
Buckle up, buttercup.
Pokémon.
Poké--
a raw fish dish from Hawaii.
Hawaii. Barack Obama.
Obama, hated by Republicans.
Republicans, Fox News.
Fox News, Roger Ailes.
Roger Ailes, who allegedly
fired Gretchen Carlson
for not having sex with him.
Ailes is a TV set blackmailer.
Anagram it.
"TV set blackmailer."
Black Lives Matter. Boom!
-(applause and cheering)
-Right there.
Got to peel the layers.
Peel 'em all.
-Boom?!
-Boom.
Yeah, but, no. No boom.
That's a giant pile
of horse (bleep).
You don't have a single shred
of proof
that the U.S. government
is behind this game.
Oh. Oh. Okay, proof--
that's what you're looking for?
-Proof?
-Okay. Yes, please.
-Proof.
-Okay, fine.
The company behind
Pokémon Go, Niantic Labs,
is run by John Hanke, who worked
for the U.S. foreign affairs.
Then started a company
called "Keyhole,"
funded by the CIA's venture
capital arm, In-Q-Tel,
funded in turn by the NGA--
National
Geospatial-Intelligence Agency.
(laughter, cheering)
Is that enough proof?
Oh, Mike. (bleep)
Is... is that all true?
-Yes, Larry.
-Oh, (bleep).
-(laughter)
-My!
-Now you're seeing.
-I... man...
Oh, I'm sorry, man.
That's actually the most
plausible thing you ever said.
-I never... The NGA?!
-Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
And what kind of intel
does the NGA collect?
N-I-G-G-A.
-Whaaat?!
-(applause and cheering)
-Hey, Mike, no. See?
See, you had me, Mike,
and now you lost me.
-Mike Yard, everybody.
-(applause and cheering)